on va là pour ce dernier document
exceptionnel de nos équipes tout juste
arrivé sur le terrain bonjour Gauthier
ravinsky on déclenché ensemble la
situation sur sur ce front j'évoquais la
situation à bakemout autant là-bas
les combats échappent à toute logique
militaire de la des experts autant à
Kerson il y a un vrai enjeu stratégique
oui ça s'explique par le fait que
on politique les comportements
politiques et les opérations militaires
sont parfois aussi mues par des affects
et non pas par la raison on sait ça
depuis qu'on a découvert un Vladimir
Poutine qui obéit à ses fantasmes c'en
est l'illustration sur personne
évidemment ces stratégiques parce que si
vous voulez il y a l'accès pour les
Ukrainiens à un sud et aussi de pouvoir
s'il verrouille personne de verrouiller
le don de base en général et de ne faire
de faire en sorte que les soldats russes
nés qu'une sortie celle vers la Russie
donc c'est important pour eux pour les
Russes
saler encore plus peut-être sur le plan
symbolique c'est à dire qu'une énième
défaite serait extrêmement problématique
même si maintenant dans le dernier
conseil de coordination les Russes
reconnaissent que l'armée est sous
équipée et que c'est un vrai problème
mais ça serait pour eux quelque chose
d'extrêmement dommageable alors que
fait-on on a bien vu il se il se taisent
les uns les autres parce que l'enjeu est
très fort je voudrais simplement
rappeler que en ce qui concerne Poutine
vous vous souvenez que lorsqu'il a
annexé illégalement donc luansk Donetsk
the prodigia et Carson il a bien dit que
c'était des territoires désormais russes
que se passe-t-il une fois que les
Ukrainiens ils y sont déjà ils sont aux
portes de klaxon pour l'instant Poutine
n'a pas réactivé cet argument mais il
faut le garder en tête parce que ça peut
être l'un des leviers pour
éventuellement éventuellement se servir
de cette fameuse bombe sale dont Poutine
attribue la volonté la paternité aux
Ukrainiens d'autant qu'il nous laisse
régulièrement entendre qu'il pourrait
être tenté d'aller plus loin notamment
hier avec ses images mais le meilleur
Poutine à superviser des exercices de
dissuasion nucléaires alors encore
faut-il expliquer en quoi cela consiste
mais le chef du Kremlin il brandit
régulièrement cette menace et on a ce
sentiment qui va toujours un peu plus
loin oui qu'il va plus loin mais de
manière assez assez graduée ou graduel
ça n'est pas excusé Poutine mais on sent
bien la volonté c'est quoi derrière ça
c'est de terroriser l'Occident pour
Vladimir Poutine en plus c'est toxine
c'est Occident et composé de poule
mouillées maintenant la question se pose
est-ce que les poules mouillées elles
ont passé chez entre temps un peu
peut-être mais surtout c'est ça cette
idée c'est de consacrer le la théorie du
Kremlin et de la Russie et d'une
certaine extrême droite que l'Occident
ce sont des gens qui prétendent avoir
des valeurs et qui ne sont même pas
prêts à se battre pour les défendre et
donc vous voyez jusqu'où on peut aller
sans jamais évacuer totalement le risque
de l'usage du nucléaire mais le fond de
l'affaire ça serait ça serait au fond de
suffisamment terroriser
l'Occident pour affaiblir son niveau de
vigilance c'est quoi la suite la suite
c'est quand par exemple Poutine aura
brandi une énième menace peut-être un
petit peu plus forte que la précédente
et que tout d'un coup il dira non c'est
terminé je n'utiliserai pas l'arme
nucléaire à condition qu'on négocie et
selon mes volontés et selon mes
intentions qu'est-ce qu'on fait en
Occident à ce moment-là on est tellement
soulagé on est tellement soulagé d'avoir
évité le pire on est tellement soulagé
de voir une guerre qui se termine parce
que en Occident on ne critique pas la
guerre sauf quand elle dure un peu trop
de temps parce que c'est plus une
opération de marketing et bien à ce
moment-là on va au négociations et on
dit merci Monsieur Poutine d'avoir
arrêté cet engrenage terrible vers
l'Apocalypse
il est pas complètement fou Poutine on
l'a déjà dit il a des affects il a les
fantasmes mais il sait c'est pas un
stratège mais c'est un tacticien il sait
comment on manœuvre les gens et ils
voient très bien la faiblesse de
l'Occident qui est une faiblesse par
rapport à un conflit que l'on ne peut
plus supporter il y a des termes
infamants qui sont on parle vous savez
de la fatigue et de la lassitude des
Occidentaux par exemple vous ukrainiens
si beaucoup Gauthier on va se on va se
quitter sur sur ces mots qui qui laisse
à méditer à réfléchir